is there such a thing as story intuition
i would lean to saying
yes i i think um
i think certain people do have
something innate within them that uh
that where they just understand
character and and they understand the
direction that stories need
to go in i think other people
might require a little bit more work to
get there
so i'm not saying that some people just
have it and some people don't i just
think some people maybe
have a little bit more of an advantage
based on where
they're from or where their mind was
focused
at on at a young age um
that seems like a very scientific answer
to a metaphysical question
where do you think you fall on that
spectrum
i wouldn't say i have all the intuition
in the world
but i do i i've been interested in
storytelling and filmmaking since i was
11 or 12 so
i every the way that i've perceived the
world has sort of been
you know with that in mind i want to
make a movie so i think that certainly
helps when you know
early on in your life that you want to
do something in
entertainment because you think in that
way and so you know your brain
becomes wired in that way and i think it
helps when
fast forward 15 years you decide to
write a screenplay
you have now spent all this time
watching movies thinking i want to do
that
and so it sort of it helps whereas there
are a lot of people that
you know might be a mechanical engineer
and then when they're
30 years old they're like actually i
want to become a screenwriter and then
it takes a little bit of
learning and a little bit of uh you know
education
to to get there and they might be you
know even
better than i was but it requires more
i guess um you know proactiveness
it requires a little bit more education
to get there
all right so on one end of the spectrum
maybe a story technician
and on the far end a story alchemist or
something yeah that's a good way of
putting it
in the middle is is sort of both okay
that sounds good do you think that if
intuitively someone doesn't know a story
that they'll never be a writer
you know you talked about the engineer
this hypothetical
writer i think i i actually believe that
anyone can be a writer i think i think
it's all just a matter of how
much you're willing to put into it to
actually tell an interesting story or
complete your story i think
everyone has a life experience that can
be interesting
in some way and
i think it's just sort of up to them to
have the will
to learn how to take that experience and
translate it into a story that anyone
can watch and anyone can understand
and anyone can enjoy
and does the life experience have to be
necessarily traumatic
definitely not no it doesn't have to be
traumatic it just has to be
it just has to be interesting and
memorable to you
and and i think
some of those stories will resonate with
a lot of people some of those stories
will resonate with a small group of
people
but i find it hard to believe that there
is
anyone in this world who has only
experienced
one thing that no one else has ever
experienced before
and even if that is the case then that
would be a pretty damn interesting story
so writers can be happy productive
people
they don't have to be absolutely
self-loathing no
they definitely don't have to be no i
think it's normal to go through
periods of self-loathing and self-loving
but yeah i don't think it's one or the
other
you